cette vidéo est sponsorisé par
cleanmymac plus d'informations en fin de
vidéo
[Musique]
à vous tous et ma vidéo comme da
tranquillement acceptera sauf juillet
des travaux
être à auch -
bah du coup on va faire la vidéo dehors
allez c'est parti en fait j'ai envie de
commencer cette année par chose que je
fais pas trop sur la chaîne pour que je
veux jamais d'ailleurs une dans la vraie
vie c'est des prédictions ars pas
vraiment des prédictions me devais tirer
ça de mon chapeau y est ça sort de nulle
part c'est plus mettre en relation je
parle des chiffres des tendances des des
données pour arriver à de potentiels
prédictions mais plus qu est ce qui
risque de se passer quoi cette année
travail que j'avais les matières
premières en prépa qui était la
géopolitique et vous allez voir que me
bats pour faire les choses bien fort
notamment touché 1
une autre matière qui est la finance en
fait les gars qui font la finance pour
essayer d'anticiper les marchés
voir ce qu'ils montrent ce qu'ils
descendent etc
ils sont obligés de sa forme énormément
et le gars plein de choses intéressantes
sur les sites d'information de finances
ok je sors je sors mon ressort
par exemple sur le coup vide j'ai trouvé
ça intéressant de confronter mon opinion
c'est vous savez des fois on a une
opinion mais c'est c'est un peu comme
une intuition après moi je suis
convaincu que l'intuition elle se passe
sur plein de choses qui se passe dans le
cerveau et que l'on process pas
forcément consciemment mais c'est
intéressant de demander aux quais bas
par exemple jpmorgan ou goldman sachs
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent du coc vide en
2022 ah ouais c je voulais que
l'ouverture était aussi fermé ici
donc qu'est ce qu'ils pensent quoi
[Musique]
j'ai pris une caméra pour bloguer two
door et je voulais à carte mémoire en
fait
je suis vraiment un blogueur en carton
c'est m en fait je n'arrive pas à me
filmer dans la rue georges voulaient
bloquer tout mais j'arrive pas
pratiquant père lachaise c'est le plus
grand cimetière de paris le jeudi aura
moins de monde
j'allais réussir à bloquer dans la revue
en fait
pour l'instant j'arrive pas mais je
soyez sur moi et on va y arriver
j'espère bien été au
château cos vide j'espère que vous êtes
à l'aise avec la mort et où vous et
faites les cimetières moi j'aime bien me
promener richesse indue touristique ou
si c'est pour ça aussi que je suis à
l'aise pour marcher en touriste est en
fait dans un cimetière à pas mal de
monde en fait on changeait d'aller
vraiment entre les allées
ya konan sachs qui dit que la dans
l'année le pib va monter de 4,5 pour
cent donc je pense qu'il parle des états
unis je suis un peu plus j'ai un petit
doute parce qu'on s'est améliorée sur le
contrôle du virus parce que il ya de
nouveaux traitements parce que il ya des
plaines top savings donc en fait c'est
des économies que les foyers ont fait
par obligation en fait parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas l'opportunité le dépenser
tout simplement donc en fait ils ont
fait des économies avec les confinements
externe il ya plein d'inventer à
reconstruire avec les ruptures de stock
et c'est donc tout ça ça va entraîner
vraiment une hausse de la croissance et
jpmorgan ils vont plus loin et pense
carrément que 2022 ce sera l'arrêt de la
pandémie avec un retour au monde d'avant
c'est que jusqu'à entend souvent avec
par exemple un traitement là le xz v10
qui vient d'être approuvée par la haute
autorité de santé ou bien même tout
simplement avec au micro en fait puisque
il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui disent
que au micron va donner une sorte
d'immunité naturelle
en plus d'être beaucoup moins létale est
donc en fait ça va naturellement
vacciner d'une partie la population
contre d'autres variant etc voilà je
voulais faire une vidéo spécifiquement
là dessus et puis au final aussi que ça
est un sujet qui était vachement traité
donc je sais que j'avais c'est tombé et
pour appuyer cette prédiction est il ya
quelques jours la ministre de la santé
espagnole qui a qui a dit en fait aux
pays européens qui devraient traiter au
micron comme on traite en fait une une
grippe à ce stade c'est plus de l'espoir
qu'une prédiction
on verra bien mais j'en ai dit quoi
l'autre prédictions qu'il faut mettre
sur la table comme ça on s'en débarrasse
vite fait c'est les élections
présidentielles 2022 moi je pense que
globalement s'arrête macron qui va
gagner
aujourd'hui il est à 24 % dans les
sondages à moins d'une énorme surprise
mais bon je la vois pas à droite c'est
très segmenté ya beaucoup de monde donc
ils se partagent un gâteau à gauche et à
personne et j'ai encore l'audace de
croire dans un front républicain
donc je pense que je pense que pour lui
ça passera au second tour et dans mâcon
président voit la prédiction pmu
prédictions pmu mais c'est aussi le jeu
des prédictions c'est ça qui est
compliqué c'est que il ya un peu ce truc
de
parfois on n'enfonce un peu des portes
ouvertes mais je pense qu'il va gagner
cette élection est un truc que je vais
dire sur le coup vide évidemment on
n'est pas à l'abri qu'il ya un super
variant qui sortent dans un pays qui
n'ont vacciné
c'est pas impossible mais je reste quand
même sur la prédiction
en 2021 il ya eu les éléments assez
important dans le monde la crypto par
exemple la tesla qui a investi 1,5
milliard de bitcoin enfin en bitcoin je
dis ça sans février en avril on a comme
bélise qui a fait ses débuts dans le
nasdaq en juin on à la chine qui a
interdit le minage un crypto en
septembre on a le salvador qui a fait du
bitcoin une monnaie légale en novembre
le beacon hill est monté à 69 milles et
à baden qui a signé une sorte de traité
infrastructures bill qui met notamment
en place une taxe liée à la crypto et en
décembre il ya eu l'équivalent des sens
parlementaire mais au capitole
concernant les crypto monnaie donc là on
voit que clairement les états commencent
à s'y intéresser davantage et il ya un
choix qui a fait rentrer le rejet et la
régulation est donc l'adoption d'une
certaine manière c'est une question que
l'inde se pose par exemple mais c'est
sûr que vu ce qui s'est passé en 2021 en
2022 les états vont devoir se
positionner là-dessus prochaine
production
c'est trop chaud parce que même si je
crois pas vraiment la vie après la mort
quand j'ai posé ma caméra sur la tombe
j'aurai deux mois autorisation et quand
je les enlever je les ai remerciés
je sais une autre caméra qui est
beaucoup moins grosse je sais pas
comment ça rend ça rend mieux ça en
moins bien etc mais le sont par contre
pensent que le son vêtement mieux
la prédiction c'est dire que 2022 sera
la première année où en fait le les
voitures électriques auront plus de deux
chiffres de part de marché c'est à dire
10 ou au dessus de 10% de part de marché
globale voilà pour la première fois vous
savoir que la croissance en 2021 des
véhicules électriques était énorme et je
venais les les chiffres de conséquence
sur certains minerais comme le lithium
et le cobalt c'est hallucinant voilà
pour vous donner une idée de ce que ça
implique des métaux comme le lithium et
le cobalt on vous leur prix bondir de 4
177% et de 208% en 2021 donc c'est
énorme c'est énorme voit la petite
prédiction sur les véhicules électriques
moi j'espère que cette caméra rend bien
je vous propose qu'on rentre chez moi
pour la suite les prédictions
moi je me dis tant qu'à faire autant que
je fasse
j'ai une machine à faire en fait donc
autant le faire
c'est un lave-linge sèche-linge il faut
que j'en enlève toutes les petites
peluches entre chaque lavage c'est hyper
chiant
à
l'aller se passer pas mal de choses
cette année qui concernait deux pays
déjà il va y avoir les mythes terme aux
états unis et les démocrates il risque
de perdre le congrès donc ça va diviser
le pays encore plus ça sera conforté
encore plus la chine puisque en gros en
termes purement géographique la
démocratie dont l'un des grands
défenseurs c'est les états unis
enfin montré ses limites en fait montre
ses limites déjà à chaque fois chaque
signe de manifestation de limite c'est
quelque chose de positif pour l'autre
camp si vous voulez et sa machine
limitant mais pour elle puisque en fait
cette année c'est une année aussi
présent pour temporaire puisque c'est le
20ème congrès du parti communiste donc
en gros les élections jin jing l'actuel
président il a fait en sorte de pouvoir
abolir le fait que l'on puisse se
présenter que pour deux mandats et donc
il va sûrement se représenter et
potentiellement être réélu il ya les jo
de pékin en hiver donc pareil ça un
moment où elle va pouvoir montrer son
pouvoir son soft power comme on dit
c'est à dire c'est pas que du pouvoir
militaire ainsi du poids culturel
pouvoir d'influencé que c'est arradon
classé via les jeux olympiques l apport
voit la montre espoirs là au monde donc
les tensions là entre entre chine et us
je pense que il ya moyen qu'en 2022
elles soient tous prononcés encore que
l'année précédente avec cette chine qui
va être de plus en plus forte on va y
revenir dans la prochaine prédiction n'a
en revanche c'est peut-être un truc sur
lequel il faut qu'il fasse attention
c'est ce stratégique au vide qui était
zéro co vide
donc 0,40 et qu il ya un cas on confine
on trace et c'est ça c'est difficile à
suivre avec des variantes qui sont aussi
contagieux au micro par exemple là où
d'autres pays occidentaux sont dans
cette stratégie de vivre avec le co lead
et sont en train d'y arriver elle la
chine en fait sa stratégie zéro co vide
qui pouvait être intéressante au début
maintenant là il faut qu'ils rattrapent
un certain retard potentiellement si
jamais elle avait pas contenir de
nouveaux vins
la course à l'espace vous savez la date
de 1957 genre avec la guerre froide donc
les russes versus les américains les
russes 157 ils ont envoyé ce pique nique
et ensuite voilà chaque pays a envoyé
des trucs dans l'espace jusqu aux
américains qui ont marché sur la lune là
c'est un petit peu voient la victoire
victoire américaine c'est la course à
l'espace elle a beaucoup changé depuis
parce que maintenant ces ennemis que
c'est plus que des états c'est aussi des
particuliers donc je pense à jeff bezos
je pense à elon musk donc jeff bezos
s'est gouré jeans et l'homme masqué xp 6
et on en parle moins mais aussi une
galactique de richard branson donc voilà
il ya des milliardaires en gros qui font
partie et qui participe à la course à
l'espace ils veulent permettre en gros
le tourisme spatial une prédiction pour
2022 il y aura plus de gens qui vont
aller dans l'espace en tant que passager
quoi
plutôt que des astronautes envoyés par
des états voilà ce serait la première
année on parle de la chine tout à
l'heure pourquoi c'est important à ce
qui va se passer en 2001 de haut niveau
de l'espace pour la chine et bien parce
qu'elles devraient avoir terminé sa
station spatiale la chine à l'ap a pu
rejoindre iss est donc assez dit bon ok
je ressens pas les s est pas tout si les
gars j'ai créé ma station spatiale donc
ça c'est en gros move et il ya certains
pays émergents aussi qui s'y met il ya
l'inde par exemple qui a prévu cette
année donc 2022 d'envoyer un robot sur
la lune voilà ce que ça donne
[Musique]
le truc a pris beaucoup de place en mai
22 c'est le metaverse
[Musique]
le métavers c'est quoi c'est la fusion
un peu entre le monde réel et le monde
en ligne à de grands plusieurs formes et
en rouge parce que vous avez aurait dit
player one c'est à peu près ça c'est un
peu ce soir aura été virtuel comme ça je
fais le malin mais je l'utiliserai
j'avoue ça m'a vachement servi en trombe
et confinement
m mais ça peut se faire aussi sans
réalité virtuelle jour par exemple
fortnight c'est une forme de metaverse
parce que c'est un lieu virtuel dans
lequel les gens vont se réunir faire des
trucs ensemble et c'est tard à quoi et
en 2021 tout ce qu'ils aiment et averses
a pris une place assez conséquente il ya
des choses qu'on n'avait pas vu avant
par exemple il ya eu un concert à
l'ariana grande et qui a rassemblé
soixante dix huit millions de joueurs
epic games qui est la boîte derrière
fortnight elle a prévu d'investir un
milliard dans le métavers ce facebook
ils ont carrément changer leur nom il
s'appelle mais tu as maintenant et ils
ont prévu de recruter dix mille
ingénieurs en europe pour créer
voilà le traverse et ils ont prévu aussi
un investissement de 10 milliards donc
d'après bloomberg donc si d'information
pour notamment tout ce qui finance en
2024 le marché des bêtes averses va
peser 800 milliards donc c'est énorme
c'est utile de faire une prédiction en
particulier précise pour 2022 mais si je
devais en faire une je dirais un concert
d'un artiste français voilà je me
mouille pas trop je pense que ça
m'arrive en 2022 on verra
le dernier truc là dans la prédiction
pour 2022 c'est celle qui m'inquiète le
plus et que je trouve la plus forte un
peu ça concerne des problèmes de
pénuries alimentaires et de ce que ça
peut entraîner en tant que révolte on
sait que quand les populations elles ont
des problèmes pour se nourrir ça
entraîne de grosses contestation
populaire l'une des dernières fois
marquantes c'était le choc
en termes de prix des denrées
alimentaires de 2011 qui a entraîné
notamment le printemps arabe donc
plusieurs contestations dans plein pays
vent et la dix ans plus tard on atteint
un niveau semblable à celui de 2011
alors les raisons elles sont simples et
multiples un mauvaise météo frais
transport plus élevé pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et ya même le prix des
engrais qui explose donc l'augmentation
elle est tellement forte que ça rappelle
ce qui a pu se passer en 2008 ou 2011 et
2011 je viens de vous le dire c'était
printemps arabe et si on regarde les
pays concernés un par ce qui s'est passé
en 2011 on se rend compte que on est
dans une situation qui est extrêmement
proche en fait voir bien pire je pense
notamment au soudan mais aussi au liban
on peut donc s'attendre à une
instabilité encore plus forte que ce
qu'on a l'habitude de voir dans ces
régions pour 2022 voilà donc ça me fait
chier parce que les prévisions vous est
donnée pas grand chose de très positif
quoi enfin si apparat par le cos vide et
tout mais bon c'était des prévisions
voilà très géopolitiques économiques
c'est un peu des choses qui sont en
deuil mais facile à prévoir parce qu'il
ya déjà des tendances parce qu'il ya des
dates précises d'un calendrier qui sont
déjà là et c'est là une prédiction que
je voulais de vous dire c'est que
l'année 2022 je vais avoir des sponsors
tu rester sur cette chaîne et ça
commence par cleanmymac alors qu in my
mac j'ai déjà eu l'occasion vous en
parlé dans une précédente vidéo c'est un
logiciel sur mac alors mac os c'est très
bien en tout cas moi j'en suis très
satisfait mais il ya quand même des
petites choses qui peuvent être
améliorées et c'est là que cleanmymac
intervient notamment par rapport à
l'amélioration des performances mais
aussi par rapport aux vulnérabilités et
si en plus vous avez un mac qui est très
ancien ça peut l'accélérer donc là je
viens danser l'ap et un bouton qui dit
analyser c'est une analyse intelligente
en fait qui va analyser les fichiers
journaux du système et le cash pouvoir
ce qui n'est pas nécessaire bon on a
trois phases en un nettoyage protection
et performance donc là nettoyage il
propose déjà de supprimer 3 avec 30 5
gigas sachant que je les reformater
réinstaller etc il ya trois semaines ce
mac entre comme sa protection il me dit
aucune menace détectée et performances
il me dit que j'ai trois tâches à
exécuter
mais bon on exécute partie donc là
nettoyage d'autres systèmes systems
exécuté l'excès de maintenance vider le
cache dns libéré la
halle et un truc que j'aime bien aussi
c'est le désinstalleur un peu
désinstaller lab de son choix par
exemple j'ai bien parce que parfois il
ya des âmes qui je trouve ça assez
compliqué à désinstaller en tout cas
c'est pas aussi simple que juste le le
drag and drop usuelles l'autre truc que
je kiffe ces télescopes télescope ça
permet en fait d'analyser son disque est
de voir visuellement où sont les données
et qu'est-ce qui prend la place sur le
disque je vais très interview avant
j'utilisais une autre appli pour faire
ça mais en fait ma main avec l'imac bas
tout est dans une seule appli est donc
c'est beaucoup mieux pour moi là je vois
que tous et surtout dans un gros dossier
et qu'en fait c'est surtout les rushs de
la vidéo que j'ai fait sur la cuisine
voilà quatre ans 50 gigas derechef faut
que je mette ça sur un disque dur
externe donc voila merci beaucoup
cleanmymac d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo encore une fois je vous mets des
liens dans l'inscription pour en
profiter c'est un des logiciels les plus
répandues sur mac pour tout ce qui est
vraiment performance tout ce qui est
nettoyage du mak maintenance et aussi
protection de tout ce qui peut être
malveillant encore merci à eux merci à
vous j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu est en soi très bientôt on va pour
une prochaine vidéo quoi la semaine
prochaine sûrement j'espère love peace
à et j'espère que ça vous a plu un peu
en mode blog et où vous me direz dans
les commentaires